so thank you so much for joining us
for climate change and global
development net zero after covet 19.
this is the seventh in a series of
yale's development dialogues which are
virtual panel discussions hosted by the
yale economic growth center the south
asian studies council
and the jackson institute for global
affairs and as you may know if you've
joined us in the past
we look to lessons from history and
economics to address today's policy
problems in
low and middle-income countries i'm
catherine chaney i'm a journalist
focused on global development and i'll
be your moderator today
and i'm joined by panelists including
sir dieter helm
who's professor of economic policy at
the university of oxford
and former independent chair of the uk's
natural capital committee
which provides advice to the government
on the sustainable use of natural
capital
plus you'll hear from rohini pandey
sunil amrith and rory stewart
who are organizers and co-hosts of this
series and i'll introduce them in just a
moment
but first just to set up the topic the
topic of green growth has come up
a few times over the course of the year
development dialogues
and there's been some debate around it
but we haven't really tackled this
head-on and that's what we'll be doing
today
so in climate negotiations low-income
countries have long asserted
that they are being asked to sacrifice
economic development
for a problem that's largely caused by
high income countries
and today western countries set bold
emissions targets
even as they continue to import goods
manufactured in low and middle income
countries
at a high environmental cost so
countries like
india may in fact increase their
reliance on coal to help mitigate the
economic devastation caused by the
coronavirus pandemic which of course has
really become a crisis in india today
even as they set targets for renewable
energy production
i should note that this dialogue is
being held on yale climate day
which is a full day of virtual events
this provides an opportunity for the
yale community and the public to come
together around pressing environmental
challenges
and you can click the link in the chat
if you're joining us on zoom
for details on other events today
including john kerry's keynote this
afternoon
as i mentioned as people were still
signing on for those of you joining us
here on zoom
please do submit your questions
throughout using the chat or q a
function
and now i want to go ahead and introduce
our panelists and move into discussion
so
uh earlier i mentioned deidre helm his
most recent book
net zero how we stop causing climate
change addresses the actions we all need
to take to tackle the climate emergency
and we'll hear more from him on that
sunil amrith is the renu and anand dawan
professor of history and current chair
of the south asian studies council
at yale his research focuses on
histories of environment migration and
public health across south and southeast
asia
rohini pandey is the henry j heinz the
second professor of economics and
director of the economic growth center
at yale
her research has examined the political
economy of aid and empowerment of the
poor
in developing countries and rory stewart
is a former member of parliament and
secretary
of state for international development
in the uk
he's written extensively about travel
politics and development and
argued against the merging of the
department for international development
and the foreign office
now known as the fcdo you may be
familiar
so i want to begin with a question for
each of you just to get
your take on the topic we're addressing
today and then we can
dive into details of what you have to
say and get into a conversation but
i think we all agree we might not agree
on the path to this but
i think we all agree that the
traditional methods of growth
must change in order to address climate
and development goals
so the question is and this is where
there might be some disagreement and
debate
what are some of the hard decisions that
need to be made and who needs to step up
so just to get your take on this topic
let's begin with
dieter if that's all right well thank
you very much and
thank you very much for asking me along
to this discussion
so almost all discussions about
environmental concerns start with the
question of
the economy and economic growth and
the alternative is put forward as either
green growth
or no growth club of rome thought that
we should have no growth at all
my take on this is that growth is
perfectly plausible
uh provided it's driven by uh technology
and ideas
and that the scope for the advancement
of
human ingenuity of technology is
enormous however
we can only consume at a level which is
consistent
with sustaining those opportunities
through time so
the fundamental environmental
observation to kick off with is
we are all living beyond our sustainable
environmental means
in other words we are consuming too much
and
the level of our consumption has to
adjust down before it can continue to go
up
into the future and why is that it's
because you
and me are ultimately the polluters and
we are not paying
the cost of our pollution including
carbon emissions
and the like and whether those emissions
are caused in india
or china or africa or they're uh
caused in london is irrelevant in the
climate change example so we have to
step
up and pay the costs of our pollution
and recognize that we're responsible for
far more pollution
than we're currently causing and that
leads to some pretty hard decisions
because
of course politicians around the world
from biden to johnson
to in the uh
are all promising to boost consumption
to solve
our current economic difficulties from
the coronavirus
and simply boosting consumption is not a
model which is going to
deliver the kinds of environmental
adjustments that need to be made
we the polluters have to adjust down and
then we have a proper level
to work on with but the politics of that
are extremely hard
thank you and when you mention we're all
living beyond our sustainable
environmental means i know your book
outlines some steps that can be taken
which we'll get into in our conversation
um but i'd love to go ahead and bring um
let's see
we'll begin with sunil if that's all
right um we'll bring sunil into this so
again i mentioned that you and rohini
and rory have been
part of conversations over the course of
this series where the topic of green
growth has come up
um and i wonder if you can expand on uh
based on maybe a historical perspective
as well which i know you bring to this
what do we do now that we're at this
crossroads who needs to step up what
hard decisions need to be made
in some ways katherine i think the
hardest decision is um the way you put
it just now you said you know we all
agree
we all agree but i suspect a lot of the
world does not agree
um and i think that the hardest task is
in fact
a profoundly political task and that is
the task for those of us who believe
that uh
a new way of thinking about growth and
the relationship between the economy and
the environment is necessary the task is
one of
persuasion really because i i don't
think um
i think there's a big disconnect between
the kinds of conversations that we've
been having on this dialogue
with with a wonderful audience engaging
with us
and the conversations that are being had
around the world
not just in developed countries but also
in developing countries
about um who should sacrifice
about what priorities are particularly
in light of this pandemic
i think you're absolutely right and so
if that is a barrier um
persuasion which i think it is uh
hopefully in our conversation we can
get to in not only hard decisions that
need to be made but
hard steps that need to be taken
including persuasion
and consensus before we can actually
make progress so hopefully we can get
into that
um rohini can i bring you into this
what's your take on this topic
um and net zero after kobit 19. how do
we get there
thanks catherine um so i think i'd
probably build off both what
dieter and sunil were talking about and
can
really remind us that in some ways
before there was economics there was
political economy
and that really i think is what needs to
be center stage
as we think about issues to do with
climate change and how we are going to
get rich in poor countries to possibly
choose different distributional burdens
so i talked about persuasion i would add
to it
the idea of how do we create incentives
so how do we actually have policies that
incentivize
rich countries to do what is arguably
good for the world but perhaps may not
be good for them
in some very narrow sense something i
know you're going to come back to that
we've already seen
with covet 19 and a lot of discussion of
vaccine nationalism
another issue i'd bring up is that of
implementation
i think a lot of discussions of climate
change policies tend to be quite legal
right now so
there's a lot of discussion of having
different countries decide how to
you know what policies to put in place
and when we look at
i think the failure of several of these
uh policies for instance those of the
kyoto protocol
a lot of them have to do again with weak
institutions that make it hard to
implement these policies
and again looking at cobit 19 and
looking for instance of the vaccine
rollout in india and how slow it is
i think it's important to remember that
a lot of the issues are going to be
you know how do we have fair technology
transfers how do we
you know think about ip issues but a lot
are going to also be about
how can um how can the global community
help strengthen institutions
and how can citizens domestic countries
ask for the institutions that will give
them the voice they need
and yeah i know you can expand on this
in our conversation but i think
if we look at covet 19 as a test for how
um developed countries can support
developing countries going through a
shared challenge um
it there are concerning implications for
our ability to respond to climate change
um given given the challenges we've seen
with coveted 19 and global solidarity
and responding to that
um rory i'd love to bring you into this
i know that
your views on these issues um include uh
your own experience as
working in policy working in development
trying to
work with countries facing these hard
decisions so
um what are what are some of the
challenges ahead and who needs to do
what
well i'm really going to comment on this
from the point of view of somebody who
was recently a politician and a minister
and i i saw three different types of
issue
one of them is domestic to britain so
when i was running
to be mayor of london uh all the polling
suggested that
the overwhelming majority of the
population was not prepared to spend
15 pounds more a year in order to pursue
environmental policies so
it's extremely important to understand
that domestic politicians running
are being told by their polling experts
and strategists
that this is not a way to get votes and
if you think about the things that we
wanted to do even at a tiny scale in
london for example on air quality
extend the clean air zone out to the
outskirts of london
which was going to impose a cost of 65
pounds
a week on people with older vehicles
from low income families
you could see why very very quickly in
the election
um people were reluctant to go there and
but that's first thing
second thing is the way in which
countries like britain deal with other
countries
that's the bilateral relationship so i
was very struck and different by the
enormous reluctance
from british development professionals
to
really emphasize climate
and the reason for that is that their
development models
very much depended particularly on
energy
so a lot of the programs that they were
most proud of which they thought would
get the greatest results
in terms of getting people out of
poverty uh involved investing
in coal-fired heavy oil-fired plants
and when push came to shelf when i
started to block those projects so i
tried to block
money going to a share loyal project in
senegal for example or i tried to stop
the commonwealth's development
corporation spending its money
on large fossil fuel burning projects in
africa there was
huge pushback enormous reluctance
even though the development community
acknowledges
that a lot of the impacts of climate
change will be felt very very
drastically by some of the poorest
people in the world
in terms of flooding in terms of soil
erosion in terms of heat right
and the argument made to me by the most
senior person differed
is that by dealing with climate change
we were
punishing today's poor for the sake of
tomorrow's poor
and then the final point which we can
turn back to which i think
you know rohini sunil and have all
touched on
is the way that this is actually
perceived from other countries
and how much uh you know india may be
reluctant
to accept these type of moves but to
take it even more extreme think about
afghanistan when i
walked across afghanistan in the winter
of 2001 2002 there was literally no
electricity between harass and kabul
none at all and as afghanistan tries to
develop obviously they're trying to
generate some electricity but this is a
country of 30 million people
if afghanistan began to go on the path
of trying to generate the amount of
electricity that a european country of
30 million people got and that that was
repeated
because you cannot imagine the scale of
a problem we're creating for the world
and yet can you imagine trying to say to
have guns
no no i'm sorry you know this isn't
going to happen okay so
on those three points i'm going to stop
because everybody else was much shorter
than me
well i do have one follow-up question
for you which is when you you're facing
that kind of pushback
and that statement as you said by
dealing with climate change we're
punishing
today's poor for tomorrow's poor um
there's also you know there it's hard to
make change right
even just institutionally no matter the
change it's hard to make change
and you mentioned that these energy
projects
which um within diffid there were a lot
of champions for these energy projects
in terms of their development outcomes
the environmental impacts were um
negative if you're making that kind of
argument and seeing that kind of
pushback it seems that it would be
helpful to point to examples of what
could work
and can you give some examples what
could work what what could be a win-win
for development and for the environment
so i mean
it is true that you can do some
extraordinary renewable energy projects
now
uh much more cheaply than you were able
to a few years ago right so
i went to see this extraordinary uh wind
project
in lake turkana in kenya and i want to
see some extraordinary solar
projects in jordan and they are
generating electricity and jordan from
solar panels at an incredibly low rate
um but i just want to dig into that a
little bit
because of course one forgets how
politics matters even with something
like a solar panel
so although they were generating
electricity from these solar panels much
more cheaply than they were generating
electricity from anything else
they weren't building anymore and the
reason they weren't building anymore was
politics
the arab spring had led to them losing
their fuel supply from egypt
they had then signed a series of
contracts for 20 or 30 years
with big international oil companies to
produce
carbon produced energy into jordan and
they couldn't get out of those contracts
they had to pay the money to
every year regardless but there was no
point in building more
solar panels for domestic consumption
and they couldn't export
because all their export lines run
through syria to turkey
and iraq which had a huge demand for the
type of power they were able to produce
so
i i just wanted to bring that to there
because it's very tempting for students
and others to think okay well why don't
we just
carpet niger with solar panels or marley
with solar panels or jordan with solar
panels
but when you actually get into these
problems the way the contracts work and
the way that the politics and conflicts
in neighboring states work these things
become much more
i'm sorry i'll try to be a bit more
optimistic in my next stance
i know that's great rory um and i want
to bring rohini in because
india came up earlier and just in terms
of zooming in on
on what this looks like and how politics
are involved as rory mentioned
um rohini can you can you provide us
some perspective looking at india
train pass through from outside my house
bad timing with a train passing through
okay but let me jump actually i wanted
to just uh
follow up on uh rory's point on uh
solar pricing and actually talk about
some work that one of our colleagues
here at yale
uh nicholas ryan has been doing right
now on
solar solar pricing and solar
uh growth of solar energy in india and i
think the point he's made
is that you know green energy suppliers
now increasingly have as rory said
low what we would call variable cost but
they still have a large
fixed cost this is partly the case also
that as you're thinking about
alternative forms of energy we often
have to think about how they're going to
fit into the grid
so what this has meant in the case of
india which is a federal country that if
you're a
producer of say um you know you're a
green energy supplier
you have to contract with the state
government in order to say i will give
you so much solar energy that'll go into
your grid
but what what this means is that most
electricity distribution companies which
are state level in india
are perennially bankrupt for a
combination of political economy and
other reasons and so there's a huge
concern of basically
renegotiation and default by the state
electricity companies which will very
often you know not be taken to court the
same way
and so this has led to in general quite
a lot of
uh counterparty risk for green energy
suppliers when they're trying to go to
the state government so they're very
willing
in nick's work right now to sell to the
central government which seems to be
doing better here
but very unwilling very often to go to
those states that are actually the
poorest states that are just about
beginning to
put in place grids where you really want
from the start
a transition to green energy but those
are exactly the states where the
suppliers don't want to go in because
they're the most concerned that they
will not be able to recover their cost
so i think that's a good example of
saying that very often we look at
technology and say wow look at the price
of solar
it's falling so fast but we have to
actually think about you know
what actually is it going to take for
these suppliers to provide it as rory
said sometimes it's international but
even within
you know a fast growing country like
india you know it can be institutional
barriers of just
or just risk that means people won't
enter
absolutely i write a lot about uh
technology and global development and
there is a lot of promise
when it comes to technology in this
space but that what will it take
question um
many barriers stand in the way and and
speaking of that i want to return to
dieter now and hear a little bit more
about your book
and and what you lay out um in the book
and i know you
you talk about what citizens and
governments can do to cut carbon
and um you know we've heard a little bit
from rory about some of the challenges
working
in government um rohini expanded on that
i'd love to narrow the focus to citizens
for a moment because earlier you were
talking about
this as a shared responsibility um and
for citizens
in low and middle income countries in
particular i'm curious
um kind of building on on rory's point
earlier
what should they be asked to give up um
and and
you know um again many challenges here
in terms of
uh asking people to do things for the
environment
that might not be in their own
self-interest um or in the interest of
their country
from a development perspective but i'd
love for you to expand on points in your
book in terms of
if we are all to take action what does
that action look like from the
perspective of citizens in low and
middle income countries
and you're on mute yeah get used to the
zoom lock in the end you know after a
year
um it's important if you ask citizens to
do
things and i deliberately focus on
citizens and not just consumers
and i'll explain that point in a moment
you have to make sure that
what they're doing is going to make some
difference and it's actually going to
address the problem
so you have to start back the beginning
with
characterizing what the climate problem
is
where it is and what would be necessary
to crack this problem
so the first thing to say is almost all
the discussion is about emissions
but the number that matters is the
concentration of carbon in the
atmosphere the stock
and the other greenhouse gases it's
sequestration
and emissions and its emissions net of
sequestration
which adds to that concentration so it's
just as important to talk about
what's happening to the amazon and how
you protect the natural assets around
the world
as it is to talk about what comes out of
a coal power station
it's not that the coal power station is
important it's just that we shouldn't be
exclusively focused on emissions without
thinking about secretary so things like
rainforests in
in brazil it's both it's emitting a hell
of a lot by burning it down
but it should be sequestrating a lot
instead and oceans
uh phytoplankton so on so that's the
first thing to say
the second thing to say is anyone who
thinks one more heave
and that'll i'm sure lead to our
discussion about cop 26
has to explain how a bit of recent
history
um doesn't fit that model so every
single year
since 1990 we've added two parts per
million to the concentration of carbon
in the atmosphere
there isn't a blip for the financial
crisis you know 708
and there was no blip last year during
the lockdowns
and that should really give people pause
for thought
if you do all of that to the developed
economies
and still you add two parts per million
to the atmosphere you know we really
have to look at this problem
very hard and i just don't i mean i'm
happy for everyone to have meet up
for 17 000 people to rock up in in
glasgow i'm very pleased that
politicians are talking about climate
change
but anyone thinks that paris really
cracked the problem and this is the
icing on the cake
they're not in the same universe as me
now the next thing that's very important
and this is back to
which citizens okay if you look at
current climate change
nearly 30 percent of emissions are from
china
okay china has more emissions
than europe and the united states put
together now
in the share of total emissions these
are staggering numbers
okay and what's more it's building more
new coal power stations than
all the coal power stations closing in
europe and in america
good that that is it's important to put
this in proportion
and at the current growth rate of china
let's say five to six percent
by 235 there'll be two chinas
so to get a real grip of the magnitude
of the problem
think about a world in which you just go
offshore from the east coast of china
and there's another one and it looks
very much like the existing one
and that will probably be true of india
too as india's growth rate goes
back up to five six and beyond and you
can just do the arithmetic
so these are stunning numbers so if you
go into that context and say so what
does it take
to crack that problem well if you just
look at emissions
you think it's the chinese it's all
their fault i've heard politicians
you know say those things privately
going forward okay so the two things to
say about it
one is that a lot of those emissions are
for you and me
so the chinese model is less so now but
was built on an
export orientated model as an indian
model may be going forward
following on from korea japan and
germany in the periods after the
post second world war period so
you have to make sure that the people
who are actually causing those emissions
to be
made actually are the people who are
paying for those emissions
the piece i'd add on top of that is that
if you think climate change is going to
get sold between now and 250 or beyond
then it's almost not all but largely
going to be in terms of additional
contribution to climate change
going to be coming from china india and
africa and brazil
philippines indonesia these are the
rapidly area uh
growing areas of the world and if they
do rapidly grow with
high levels of mission whatever the
justice of that
we will face that very hot climate
change so
if we are really interested in making
these changes
we the citizens of the countries with
much higher
consumption ahead have to make sure we
pay for the emissions in those countries
and now what do their citizens do well
i'd put it the other way around
what are their citizens entitled to so i
say citizens
because in my environmental approach
what i want to do
is to make sure that all citizens have
the basic capabilities to function in
society
you can see that i did my thesis under
march ascend to see where this argument
comes from
so it's a positive entitlement to assets
not utility
not the economist normal currency it's
making sure they have the wherewithal
within which to live their lives the
most important where with all to do
that is to have the natural capital
assets
the environmental assets to make their
lives tolerable
the only way that's going to happen as
the indian energy minister
made clear a couple of weeks ago uh is
that
there has to be substantial transfers to
make that possible
and i think the most frightening thing
about paris and any discussions about
glasgow is that people are talking about
well couldn't we go from 100 billion
to 200 billion to address the transfers
that might be required
you know we in britain spent 300 billion
just on covid
right this is an order of magnitude
different
and the difference between the covidien
episode and the climate change one
is the kovid one enables an element
of national wall building and
uh nationalistic protection which we've
seen let loose
there is no wall you can build not even
one that mr trump could imagine
which will keep a ton of carbon emitted
anywhere out of the world
into our climate so i think we have to
think about global citizens and their
entitlements
we have to think about it as an assets
not flows
and we have to think about it in the
capabilities that go with that
not just trying to make them happy and
think it's some utilitarian exercise
in maximizing economic welfare thank you
and i'm glad you brought up this point
around
natural capital which i hope we can
return to because i think
too often it's presented as a trade-off
in terms of
you know protecting the planet at a cost
to your country's development path but
when you bring in natural
capital as a lens through which to look
at this um you can
identify more of these win-win
opportunities one very quick come back
on that please there's a lot of people
who think there's a trade-off between
the environment
and economic growth between natural
capital and
gdp tomorrow okay and at the same breath
they'll accept that what we're currently
doing is unsustainable
so the conclusion that follows from
something that's unsustainable
it will not be sustained and the problem
is
and the problem of convincing people in
europe and the united states
is that the people who are really going
to get the brunt end of it not being
sustained
it's actually not us we've got a lot of
technologies we've got air conditioning
we've got all sorts of things
it's the poor that get the consequences
and that's what makes the politics nasty
because it says actually you know what
if we don't do what's necessary to
address climate change
we get the effects last they get them
first
and that sequencing is quite important
it's really well put
go ahead rory coming very quickly i mean
i think you know
details produced a very stark and very
important thing there
um remember it's also true to some
extent
within uh wealthy countries that it's
often the poorest people
who are at the center of this political
problem
so if you think of relatively
straightforward policies that british
governments tried to implement
for example we tried to increase fuel
tax there was an
escalator set up where fuel tax was
meant to go up every year
that was stopped the labour party
campaigned very strongly on trying to
control
energy prices because
the people that increasingly are the
focus
of political activity could be
the rust belt in the united states could
be the red wall voters in britain and
northeast britain
um are often people who already feel
that their incomes have stagnated
that there is extraordinary inequality
that they are really struggling to get
by
and the basic things like running their
car
or heating their house so taking a very
large amount of their income
so many of the most straightforward
policies that we would want to pursue
will have an impact on them
and that's going to also relate to
something at the heart of diesel's
proposal
essentially is proposing that there is a
tax
on our consuming of these products right
so um
the more products that we consume made
in china the more that we will
pay but of course the people who will
feel that most are the people that are
driving a lot of the political
discontent and are defining a lot of the
politics
uh in europe and the united states thank
you
thank you and on this point about um you
know i think rory you teed it up nicely
it's not just about
um rich versus poor countries it's about
poverty and inequality within countries
i know that's something
rohini can speak to do you want to jump
in on this i'll just briefly
jump in and you know maybe also be a
little bit more provocative
um you know i think we can only go so
far if you think of this in terms of
geography
and countries because in the end you
know
there are many people in countries like
india and brazil and even china who are
really not consuming very much
and it may be that at the country level
that's where the costs are
but we have to recognize that you know
consumption of the poorest is still
something that needs to rise a lot
one recent thing i saw that was
interesting was a few years ago
uh branch milanovic had very had made
very
well known there's elephant curve
talking about global income and
i recently saw an oxfam report that had
what they called the dinosaur graph
similarly showing how emissions varied
by
income and you know showed that
basically a lot of if you if you try to
do emission um counting not at the level
of
countries but at the level of
individuals you see the same pattern
that there
is the rich who are really consuming a
lot so i think one thing we need to
start thinking hard about when we think
of these cuts
is not to have all the discussion at the
country level but move it down to
again what i think is happening in the
income space thinking about wealth tax
or inequality tax
and so one final point just to think
about that is you know we need to start
thinking about corporations and
companies
just as i think when wealth tax so for
instance very often i talked about how
solar providers are finding it hard to
enter
indian states nick actually has earlier
papers showing how fossil fuel companies
tend to enter this 30-year contracts
uh with states and then renegotiate them
so they're going to be many cases where
just as
i think in the inequality income
inequality space there's now a very
robust
discussion about the need for wealth
wealth tax in the u.s some kind of
corporate taxation in the uk
we need to start thinking about in the
environmental space
at the level of what we think are the
large individuals and corporations that
are emitting
not make it just about countries
so i want to bring sunil in here with a
historical perspective india has come up
a few times
and as i mentioned earlier and as many
of you are following i'm sure
as this country faces the second wave of
kobit 19
it's a real crisis and sunil over the
course of this series you
and other historians have linked
different examples of south asian
history to current policy decisions
and i wonder if you can speak to whether
it comes to
responding to covet emerging from covid
um and and tackling um this issue of
climate making these hard decisions
what are examples from india's past that
might inform policy decisions that need
to be made now
i mean it increasingly seems to me that
what we need in india is
is in a sense nothing short of the kind
of foundational conversations that were
had in the middle of the 20th century
which
many of my colleagues have been working
on um the sense of that conversation in
the mid
40s to the late 40s when the fundamental
questions were asking what sort of
polity what sort of society what sort of
economy is this going to be
um i'm not optimistic that political
conditions are are particularly
propitious for that kind of conversation
but i am struck by how much of the
unfinished business of that earlier
moment
we are now dealing with so that was a
transformative moment um the universal
franchise was introduced in a country
with profound levels of social and
economic inequality
which many people at the time said would
be impossible um
one of the things that did not happen in
the 1940s and there's a very very
interesting uh graduate student at
harvard called kieran kumbar who's
working on this at the moment one of the
things that did not happen
was nothing was done to address the
chronic underinvestment in public health
that had been a characteristic of the
colonial state in india
and throughout 20th century and into
this century india spends a smaller
proportion of gdp on health than just
about any country in the world
we're seeing the consequences of that
now and i mean in some sense one of my
puzzles and this has been true for many
many years is why health has never
really been a political issue in india
um not at the state level yes from time
to time but never
it's not something that wins elections
this is something that goes back to what
rory was saying earlier about
you know the citizens of london voting
for their mayor
were not perhaps willing to spend even
15 pounds um to address environmental
questions
this is a much more puzzling question
because health affects everybody it
affects the poorest most
um and this has not been a topic at
least maybe until now
for for massive mobilization um the
other connection that i want to make in
terms of india it goes to something that
vegeta was saying this is very
interesting
so the lancet found that in 2019 air
pollution was responsible
for 1.6 million deaths in india um the
year before that
nearly as many we're talking you know
over two or three years in india
um as as many people die from air
pollution
as have died through this terrible
global pandemic on a global
scale it i don't think it's an
exaggeration to say that air pollution
has not received nearly
as much media attention or provoked as
much anxiety or concern
as this pandemic so i think this goes to
what detail was saying about you know
this
there are no walls we can build in terms
of carbon emissions for example
um unlike perhaps some of what we've
seen with the pandemic
um so so there are questions i'm not
sure there are lessons from indian
um history but more sort of unfinished
business that we need to
sort of return to the fundamental going
to what rohini was saying institutional
questions political questions about
you know how to prioritize public health
and from there
to think about public health in a way
that goes beyond the emergency of covet
to the ways the causes of air pollution
for example are far more
aligned with what we're talking about in
relation to the climate crisis and
energy consumption
just very quickly say that i mean i
think there's something very important
in sunil's
conversation about that foundational
moment in the 1940s and 50s in india
because
it's impossible to get around the fact
that there is an ethical dimension to
this
that ultimately in order to make our way
through this
is going to involve some very very
dramatic element of sacrifice
transformation
and difficult political choices and
somewhere hovering underneath the
surface of this conversation
is the fact that actually what dietrich
and rohini have explained
is the impossibility
of generating massive increases in
consumption
and controlling climate change which
means that in the end
our societies our politics have to find
a way
of talking about morality even though as
a politician
you know i'm very very conscious of how
easy that is to say
and how very difficult that is to pull
into an election campaign
let me just sorry i'm jumping in a lot
but let me just jump in on one thing
that rory
said uh i think the implications it also
has for policy and i'd love to hear
uh detail on this we often as economists
talk a lot about the most efficient
policy so for instance we talk about
carbon tax
i think rory very clearly pointed out
why something like a carbon tax on fuel
through fuel tax may not work and so
this suggests that
even as we start designing policies i
think we need to think a lot more about
distributional
and fairness issues as part of this
ethical issue
which for instance may suggest that
sometimes rationing
which we think of as quite an
inefficient policy may actually be one
that is you know perceived
as fairer and we should get to it so you
know economists
quite often talk about uh what they
would call second best policies
uh but they often think of second best
because there is some market missing
i think we might need to think about
that what are the best environmental
policies
need to take into account kind of issues
of ethics or morality of distribution
and may look quite different from what i
think a lot of economists right now are
pushing as sort of the technocratically
best policies like carbon tax
great point quickly i'll just say we
have a lot of questions coming in on
exactly this like what policies should
we see moving forward so this is great
go ahead dieter
um so so i i very much agree there's
ethics at the heart of this and and the
way i'd kind of
uh encapsulate that is you have to work
out how future citizens are going to
have a seat at the table
and they're going to have a seat at the
table either because
we haven't made the sacrifices and their
seat at the table is to make the
sacrifices
or we're going to take into account
their interest going forward and my
argument that we should ensure that each
and each citizen inherits a set of
assets natural assets at least as good
as they inherited
is an ethical principle but i also want
to pick up this point that rory raised
about fuel taxes etc
and this linked to to carbon pricing
okay so it's very interesting
as i understand it mr biden doesn't want
to put out fuel taxes either
and it's very very it's not just a kind
of uk
thing or a particular political party
thing you know
you tell the public you know what it's
it's better than a free lunch you know
the
climate change we're going to solve it
because ain't going to cost much of gdp
it's all going to happen the cost of
renewables are cheaper than fossil fuels
you know it's like the 20 pound notes
lying on the ground
and we just got to pick them up and it
may actually be gdp positive
okay and i said to myself is this
likely to which my answer is absolutely
no
unfortunately um is it likely that we
can transfer from an overwhelmingly
carbon intensive economy to one that
isn't carbon intensive economy
within 30 years no and therefore you get
to this political
what i call inverted commas lie which is
tell them we're going to do it and tell
them it isn't going to cost anything
mr johnson put this in biden's summit
a couple of weeks ago as saying um that
he was going to have cake-ism you could
have your cake and eat it too
that's morally irresponsible right
and we will have to increase the price
and we can either do it of carbon either
directly
by having a carbon price and we do in
europe we do in the uk actually most
people have carbon prices because they
have energy taxes in some form another
or we can do it implicitly we can say
we're not going to take the most
efficient route because we don't like
the politics of it
so let's find a route that's less
efficient well the answer that is is
going to cost you even more than the
first route did
okay so i don't think carbon pricing is
impossible
it exists uh harmonizing energy taxes
would get us a long way towards it
but the bit about carbon pricing that i
really want is the border adjustment
so that we don't pretend amongst the
developed countries that when we reduce
our carbon territorial production to net
zero
we're going to stop causing climate
change uk is 80
services we have no large energy
intensive industries left
we pride ourselves at being the leading
country in the world in reducing
emissions
this is the way to go guys right and
actually
the truth is our carbon consumption is
displacing our carbon production
it's very much higher and that's because
we're just not
paying for our true carbon footprint and
paying for your true carbon footprint
is at the base of any moral or ethical
approach
to climate change here and anywhere else
and since we're doing most of the
consuming
and by the way we put up 80 percent of
the stuff in the atmosphere that's
already up there
it's natural that it's our consumption
in the developed countries
that has to come first in this equation
and not to tackle that
by telling people you don't have to have
a higher fuel price you don't have to
pay for higher gasoline it's not going
to cost you anything
it's just delusional and the consequence
will be
that we will have that climate change
and then back to the early point of
discussion
the people who really going to suffer
are in developing countries
some in developing countries too in
developed countries too
but remember compared with as witnessed
in the indian case with covet at the
moment
compared with some of the developing
countries even the less well-off
in the developed countries have some
kind of safety net
which unfortunately doesn't exist for
most of the world's population
very true i i want to bring in some
questions from the audience
and we have some great ones coming in
and i'd remind you all please use the q
a function on zoom if you're joining us
on zoom to submit those
um there is a question related to
technology and i think we
we kind of started with um technology as
a given like
we have the technologies and so it's
about persuasion and incentives and hard
choices but
a question on that technology um so
won't global adaptation to green energy
only happen when cost effective and
dependable technologies
make that adaptation desirable without
being forced by government policies
in that regard isn't isn't research into
critical obstacles like energy storage
and safe nuclear
the most important thing to focus on now
so i appreciate the question because
again we kind of just plowed through the
technology point and this um
forces us to return to that question you
know what more do we need on the
technology front
even as we are tackling all these other
issues in terms of
uh incentives and ethics and um
persuasion any thoughts on technology
can i have a go please um and i said
technology right at the beginning
the reason why economic growth is
possible is because technology is
pushing out and
aside from robert barrow's book actually
the evidence is the speed of technical
progress has never been greater
and this really matters for climate
change not just for the emissions
but the sequestration too so 25
of global emissions at least come from
agriculture
soil on average has four times the
carbon of the atmosphere
that's the biggest stock of carbons
below our feet and agriculture rips that
out pretty quickly
especially unfortunately in some of the
developing countries
if you look at what's going on in
genetics if you look at what's going on
in gene editing
if you look at the transformation that
digital information has created
for agriculture that's a revolution it's
making
when it comes to the energy side
there is of course great technical
progress
the problem is that almost all the
hope and aspirations are placed on two
decentralized low energy density
technologies which cannot in themselves
produce the kind of power
required for the economy at the world as
it is at the moment
net alone what's coming i'm talking
about wind and solar solar by the way is
much more promising than wind
you know you need a lot of wind turbines
and a lot of backup and a lot of
batteries
a lot of storage and all that's
important but i think it's delusional to
think
that we're going to solve climate change
with
wind turbines and solar panels alone we
need quite a lot more
that requires an honest discussion about
technology
first of all the enormous resources that
ought to go into
genuine r d which is a fantastically on
average good uh investment for public uh
for publics to make even if
the chances of each one succeeding is
quite small and we have to make some
choices about whether we're really
prepared to do this
and i'm not advocating we should without
big scale
energy as well as small scale and that
means hydrogen
nuclear and things of that sort and
we're not there yet
but we will not crack climate change
unless we have
both the technology and the adjustment
of the consumption frame
neither of them will do it on their own
on their own
thank you and thanks for that great
question any any uh other panelists want
to jump in on technology otherwise we
have other questions coming go ahead
rainey
yeah i just had one quick thing which uh
you know it reminds me a bit
of um sort of the
focus in the west coast for instance and
a lot of
tech driven for development policy i
think
10 years ago this was the thing that we
were going to just send
you know phone on mobile money on mobile
phones and that was going to solve all
the problems the redistribution and
i think one thing we discovered is it
didn't get the whole way there not
because mobile phones are not
an amazing good or that we that sending
money didn't help people but you know
there were countries that the regulatory
agencies said they didn't want to allow
for mobile money because they were
worried about risk to their banking
system and so on so
i think my only note of caution is i
completely agree with dieter that we
need i think
significant r d but i think we shouldn't
do it at the expense of thinking that
that technology
uh you need to think about you know what
how a regulator is going to react to it
are they going to be willing to put it
in and you know even technology can
cause trade-offs between short-term
as rory described you know poverty
reduction measures and longer run
returns so you may have a great
technology
but what it might ask a country to do in
the short run may make it politically
very tractable
and i think if we could start having
those conversations or even think about
them at the time when you're financing
technology
i think we could learn a lot from at
least what hasn't worked i think in
development policy despite great
technological advances
there's another question here related to
the private sector
and i'm loving these questions because
they're all very action oriented the
role of technology the role of the
private sector and i'll just preview in
a moment the role of universities
there's a question around that which i
think would be fascinating for this
group to take on
but let's talk about the private sector
so the question is
almost a thousand companies have signed
on to the science-based targets
initiative
pledging to set emissions reduction
targets consistent with the paris
trajectory
along with major companies setting
similar carbon neutrality goals
so in what ways can these ambitious
targets in private enterprise
help support and even spur governments
to step up their own commitments can the
private sector
help lead the way does it play a
meaningful role
thoughts on that
rohini yeah i can jump in i mean i think
i think it's great i think it's great to
see
voluntary efforts but i think we should
think about kind of the hard questions
at the heart of this for a lot of
companies really taking climate change
hard
climate change seriously is about losing
money right if you are a fossil fuel
company
there is no way that this is actually
good news for you so we have to
recognize that while
voluntary actions will get us some of
the way it's not going to be the
the only way in which private sector
needs to be moved sometimes you do need
the state to come in as a regulator
uh you know pushing private companies to
take actions that they won't want to
i think one other thing to bear in mind
also that
it's very easy for companies to announce
they're going to be net zero by a
certain date
it's quite another when you look behind
the bonnet what they actually think
they're going to do
and they're two parts that first of all
remember companies don't exist for the
fun of being companies they exist to
sell
stuff to you and me so when companies
pollute
the customer who buys the product is
actually the ultimate polluter
and this is facilitated so we we
castigate all companies but we go and
fill
up the car with petrol or diesel right
you can't have it both ways you've got
to put in the frame
but the bit i just want to illustrate is
a lot of companies say well you know
we're
we're investing in trying to get
emissions out of our production plant
but you know what we've done a load of
offsets
and you really have to look very hard at
what constitutes an offset and it looks
like
nearly half of what companies are
claiming to be
their net zero path
is actually just buying into renewables
projects many of which would have to
happen
anyway you have to be very careful this
isn't the religious
version of buying indulgences you know
let me go on
doing what i'm doing but i'll pay a side
payment to try to
explain myself now that doesn't in any
way detract from the need for companies
to take this stuff
seriously but i think this cascade of
people declaring themselves net zero
needs just a little bit of cautious and
critical
examination agreed and i throw out
as a journalist that journalism plays an
important role there not just um
featuring the announcements but asking
you know what's actually happening
um rory did you want to jump in on this
question yeah
i mean i i i think that's sort of
just to sort of step back the um the
fundamentals that we keep coming back to
which
i think everybody keeps emphasizing is
that if the
scale of the problem is as large as
we're pointing out
and the forms of sacrifice required are
that extreme
and it's extremely unlikely that you're
going to be able to
do this without a very significant
impact on growth consumption etc
it's intuitively very very unlikely
that private companies are going to be
able to to lead this for all the reasons
that teaching refugees laid out
thank you i want to actually directly
ask this question around universities
especially because we are
um you know wrapping up for this
academic year the yell development
dialogues
um so the question is what is the role
of our universities in this whole
process
as knowledge and as dialogue um
with the world so um i think that's a
that's a good point why why are we
having this conversation and
and what more can universities do um in
terms of
of helping to carve the path forward
rory did you want to jump in
yeah well let me come quickly as the one
person who really isn't entitled to
speak about this at all given that i've
got
distinguished professors on the call um
but for me
as somebody who was a politician until
very recently and i'm now at a
university
it is unbelievably refreshing and
valuable
to be able to have these types of
conversation the last 45 minutes of
conversation
simply doesn't happen in politics for 10
000 reasons to do with the way that
elections work the attention deficit of
politicians
the general muggy thinking um
if one were able to take simply the last
45 minutes of conversation and actually
embed it
in the way that biden or boris johnson
or macron thinks about the world but it
makes the most extraordinary difference
and and that's the
you know that's why for me at least uh
universities are incredibly useful
because it allows you to say things
which are
totally brutal because i can also assure
you as a next working politician
at least six things that everybody said
which would ruin their political careers
in the last 45 minutes
i love it thank you rory do others want
to jump in on this the role of
universities i guess a question for me
is how do we
pull these kinds of conversations into
the halls of government
into um the heads of policy makers as
they're navigating
these hard disks both ways around isn't
it i mean
you know give you an example just a few
hundred yards from
here a group of scientists
got hold of the um genetic frame map of
the
coronavirus and within just over a week
it invented a vaccine
you don't get that anywhere else because
you don't get that
independent long-term research and you
know the ultimate driver of economic
growth
and actually the ultimate driver of hope
to address climate change is ideas and
ideas
are not always produced in universities
but it's damn hard to drive them forward
without universities
and without engaging with the next
generation
who are going to inherit this planet and
hopefully with a few more
natural capital assets than we're
currently on course to lead them
to neil go ahead a few things um in
terms of that interface between
these kinds of discussions and and you
know the world of policy
my main source of optimism in general is
is our students i mean i think they are
the main conduit between the kinds of
conversations that we can have in the
classroom and you know many of them will
go on to
be journalists and politicians and
policy makers and so i
that for me remains the single most
important thing that universities do
is is the teaching um as well as our
research of course
um as someone in the humanities i've
been involved with a lot of
conversations with so many of my
colleagues about how we fold
climate change completely into what we
do not not as a sort of
just another topic that we study but you
know how do we rethink the humanities
um with the climate contract crisis at a
very
foremost of our consciousness i think
there's a lot of conversations happening
around that
but the last thing i want to say about
universities and climate change um
picking up on many things that have been
said in this conversation is we need
some honesty about that too
i'm not sure that universities um pay
for their carbon footprints
um i'm not sure particularly
universities like yale and and others
with very large endowments um have fully
thought through
um the responsibilities on that side of
things
you sunil and we just have a few minutes
left so i want to close with one
question and i'm sorry
um for those great questions we weren't
able to get to um a lot of good
questions coming in but
cop 26 has come up a few times and
um you know some of our panelists have
discussed
that we have these meetings you know
commitments are made and yet um as
dieter mentioned earlier
emissions continue like we start to lose
hope in the process um so with cop26
around the corner
taking place in the context of covid19
um
we only have about 30 seconds or so from
each of you but
what's one thing you want to see happen
what what could rich and poor countries
do
between now and november or i should
broaden it since we talked about it's
not just
a matter of geography what should
citizens do between now and november
whether it's citizens whether it's
policy makers what's one thing you want
to see to improve the prospects
for real progress to be made at cop26
and maybe we'll we'll start with our
co-hosts and then conclude with dieter
if that's all right um rohini can i
begin with you
sure um you know this is also trying to
just pick up on one of the questions
in the in the in the in the q a
i think one thing we didn't touch upon i
think is going to be critical that we
start seeing honest conversations on
is the idea of carbon capture and
storage i think most models of growth
right now that try to be sustainable
are built on large amounts of
sequestration of ccs happening
we don't understand anything about i
think of the economics of it how it's
going to be achieved how will this
happen
my concern is in something like cop26
that can become the
big thing that everyone says we will do
a lot more carbon capture and
sequestration
but you know this is not realistic at
all so i think having
kind of more honest conversations on
that would be very valuable
thank you i'll go to rory next if that's
all right
um i i think cop 22 is really the
opportunity
for politicians to do something that
politicians particularly in an age of
populism find very difficult
which is to get away from cakes and get
away from having your cake and being
able to eat it
and focusing instead on detailed
uncomfortable treats and if there's one
message that you want to try to get
it is that what we will have to do is
going to have an impact on our greatest
assumption if you can just get that
single message through
and suggest to people that there will be
pain and there will be sacrifice
involved that's probably the most
important beginning for this
conversation
great point thank you sunil an honest
conversations seem to be the theme of
our conversation now and i think that
that is what is needed
um i i think as a humanist i think
narrative matters and what i would like
to see
citizens and scholars and activists do
is is to find a way of linking what
we've all been through with this
coronavirus pandemic
with a much longer term future and the
fact that the climate crisis and
the coronavirus crisis are connected in
many many ways
and we've been deeply conscious of one
of these crises and
willfully ignoring the other for the
most part um so i would like to see
um you know stories narratives ways of
linking these things in ways that are
meaningful to people
absolutely agree with you dieter we'll
close with your thoughts on
on what needs to happen between now and
cop 26 for this to really make a
meaningful difference
well i think that whereas the
politicians are all
queuing up to make announcements about
numbers many of which they don't
understand and i'm not against that
process
i would like the concentration to be
shining the torch on what's really going
on
i would like a reconnection between
natural capital biodiversity and climate
change this is a global environmental
crisis not just a climate one i would
like the accounting done properly
so we measure who is really responsible
for carbon
i'd obviously like carbon pricing
because i want the polluters to pay
and finally i think what i'd like
individuals to do
citizens to do is write their own carbon
diary
and look very hard into their own lives
and write down
how much during the average day they
think is the carbon emissions that they
are responsible through their
consumption
and ask themselves how in 30 years time
they're going to write the same carbon
diary as a citizen
with no carbon in it and then they'll
get a measure
of the sheer scale of the task in front
of us which we must address
because if we don't the consequences
will address
us well put in a powerful call to action
to close us out
um so it's my task now to wrap up this
is a fascinating conversation thank you
to all of our panelists
and as our 2020 season of the all
development dialogues comes to an end
we're beginning to plan our series for
the next academic year and we would
really love all of your input on the
topics we should cover
so when you exit this webinar you'll be
linked to a feedback form
it shouldn't take more than just a few
minutes to fill out and as a thank you
you'll be entered into a drawing for a
collection of books
by different panelists we've featured
over the course of this series including
dieter's latest book
net zero how we stop causing climate
change so thank you to all of our
panelists and thanks to all of you for
joining us